all right ladies and gentlemen
we're back
here tonight to help me learn some of
the secrets of movie stuntmen as our
good friend professional stunt
coordinator Stephen ho Stephen good to
see you again
you and I have done some stunts in the
past and we asked you to come back on
this new show and and do something with
me and you said you wanted to take it up
a notch get a little more dangerous I
said why not
what have we got planned so today's
class is all about learning how to evade
you've made Split Second decisions
against weapons okay all right we've
done that before yeah we went to the
next level okay now when you say take it
to the next level What specifically do
you mean what are we going to do well
we'll go there let's start off with our
training Staff first okay this is
actually a training staff all right this
is a training staff that's a long
broomstick with a boxing glove yes tied
to the end hello Hi how are you good
okay okay that's something from the
audience
as I said we need security
because I may hit you in the face so
just to make sure
don't hit me in the face
I've done this with a lot of actors no
one's actually ever complained so it'll
be all right thank you
okay all right
of course they're all dead uh all right
so uh this goes here I'm having trouble
with the mask not a good sign so again
this is a uh huh
this is supposed I'm fine I'm just
kidding around that's protective gloves
so it's it's not gonna hurt you let me
get loosened up here it's like hold on
all right now what are we doing
um basically we're just gonna hey
what the hell was that all about I just
wanted to show you that this doesn't
hurt very much yeah
yeah okay okay all right now what about
the evading part
you stay in place oh and it comes down
as hard as I can here okay you just
evade to that right that way that's okay
okay all right come down really hot now
right yeah all right right to your head
right there now which way am I going
this time same way okay okay and then
now we're gonna come at you the opposite
direction so slip the other direction
very good that's a nice sound very nice
okay
okay nice next I'll swing it over your
head so just weave under duck under yeah
okay try not to um try not to watch try
to try to duck like a fighter not like
you're going to the bathroom
[Applause]
maybe I was going to the bathroom
so so that way
now right when you're there I'm gonna
come right at your leg so jump jump jump
okay cool okay okay yeah here we go now
we're gonna put the whole thing together
we'll put the whole thing together and
then afterwards we'll go off the book a
little bit and we'll just do some ad-lib
stuff and you can see this part first
all right here we go
[Music]
let's do it again and then right
afterwards we'll go ahead
sound effects suck
all right okay here we go yeah okay
all right
[Applause]